This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. On the afternoon of June 18th in the Los Angeles neighborhood of Echo Park at the intersection of sunset boulevard and Logan Street, people were going about their day, having brunch at trendy cafes and perusing a local bookstore. When suddenly, they saw something extraordinary. A battle between good and evil. That's reporter and friend of the show, David Weinberg.
这里是“99%隐形”。我是罗曼·马尔斯。6月18日下午，在洛杉矶的回声公园社区，日落大道与洛根街的交汇处，人们正过着他们的日常生活，在时尚咖啡馆享用早午餐，在当地书店浏览书籍。突然，他们看到了非同寻常的一幕。一场正义与邪恶的较量。那是记者兼本节目之友大卫·温伯格。
Some of the people who saw the confrontation probably thought a movie or a commercial was being filmed. Why else would a guy in a superhero outfit attempt to move a car with his bare hands? It all started when a woman in a white cheap pulled up to the traffic light to make a right turn onto sunset boulevard. Now, it's perfectly legal to make a right turn on red in California. What you're not supposed to do is block the crosswalk while you wait your turn. And that's exactly what happened here. It was at this precise moment that our hero emerged from the shadows to save the day. He was wearing a black and white striped cape and a mask.
目睹这场对峙的人中，有些人可能以为是在拍摄电影或商业广告。不然为什么一个穿着超级英雄服装的人会试图用双手去推动一辆汽车呢？这一切都始于一辆白色雪佛兰里的一位女士把车开到红绿灯前，准备右转进入日落大道。在加州，红灯右转是完全合法的。你不该做的是在等待转弯时堵住人行横道。而这正是这里发生的事情。就在这个精确的时刻，我们的英雄从阴影中现身，来拯救世界。他戴着黑白相间的斗篷和面具。
This caped crusader bravely approached the front of the car, placed his hands on the hood and started pushing. My name is Piatonito. I'm the pedestrian luchador of Vigilante of the streets, fighting for pedestrian rights. El Piatonito, He's a real life superhero. Yeah, I don't like to much the word superhero. I feel it sounds pretentious, I don't know.
这位披着斗篷的卫士勇敢地走到车头前，把双手放在发动机罩上开始推车。我叫皮亚托尼托。我是街头的行人自由摔角手兼义务治安员，为行人的权利而战。埃尔·皮亚托尼托，他是个现实生活中的超级英雄。是的，我不太喜欢“超级英雄”这个词。我觉得这听起来有点矫情，我不知道。
But I like more vigilante or in Spanish, the word luchador, that it's a fighter, a fighter of the streets. El Pea Toneito models his look on Mexican wrestlers. But this hero does not wage his battles in the ring. He fights in the dangerous, smog-choked, traffic clogged metropolises wherever the humble pedestrian faces their most dangerous villain, the automobile. The people of Los Angeles are very much in need of a hero like El Piazzanino. Because in many ways, the city's leaders have failed to protect them from automobiles.
但我更喜欢“义务治安员”或者西班牙语里的“luchador”，也就是一个斗士，一个街头斗士。皮亚托尼托的外型以墨西哥摔角手为蓝本。但这位英雄不在擂台上战斗。他在充满危险、烟雾弥漫、交通堵塞的都市中战斗，只要谦卑的行人面临最危险的恶棍——汽车。洛杉矶的人们非常需要像埃尔·皮亚托尼托这样的英雄。因为在许多方面，这座城市的领导者未能保护他们免受汽车的伤害。
Every 30 hours, a person in Los Angeles is killed in a car-related incident. It's the leading cause of the children in California car crashes, and all because we wanted to go fast in the streets. And the main job of the government is to protect our lives. The life is sacred. El Péa Tnito is not some lone crusader fighting for us mortals. There are real life superheroes all over the world, scouring the streets of their towns, doing their part to fill in the gaps
在洛杉矶，每30小时就有一人死于与汽车相关的事故。这是加州儿童车祸的头号死因，这一切都只是因为我们想要在街道上开快车。而政府的主要职责是保护我们的生命。生命是神圣的。埃尔·皮亚托尼托并不是为我们这些凡人战斗的孤胆英雄。世界各地都有现实生活中的超级英雄，他们在各自城镇的街道上搜寻，尽自己的一份力量去填补
where local authorities have failed. David recently made a whole podcast about real-life superheroes. It's called the superhero complex. While working on it, I discovered a whole world of costume vigilantes and do-gooders, some of whom were hell-bent on catching criminals and getting into fights, but Alpe Attenito was part of a different subset of real-life superheroes, who were more focused on things like picking up trash and taking on civic issues. They take their inspiration from comic books, but in some ways, these real-life heroes have more ambitious goals than defeating a make-believe villain.
地方当局力所能及的盲区。大卫最近制作了一整期关于现实生活超级英雄的播客。它叫做《超级英雄综合症》。在创作它的过程中，我发现了一个充满着化装义务治安员和慈善者的世界，其中有些人一心只想抓罪犯和打架，但埃尔·皮亚托尼托属于现实生活超级英雄中的另一个子集，他们更专注于捡垃圾和参与公民议题等事情。他们的灵感来自漫画书，但在某些方面，这些现实生活中的英雄比打败一个虚构的恶棍有着更宏大的目标。
They are out to solve big societal problems, wherever a city is plagued by traffic accidents or people are living on the streets, these heroes heed the call of service. When I first heard about real-life superheroes, I was skeptical of them. I thought surely they just wanted attention, whilst they dressed up in ridiculous costumes. But then I started to spend time with some of them,
他们旨在解决重大的社会问题，无论一座城市饱受交通事故的困扰还是有人露宿街头，这些英雄都会响应服务的召唤。当我第一次听说现实生活中的超级英雄时，我是持怀疑态度的。我想他们肯定只是想要引起注意，同时穿着荒谬的服装。但后来我开始花时间与其中一些人相处，
attacked along on neighborhood patrols, and-hand the work they were doing. And I came away inspired by their dedication to helping people in need. And I felt guilty about judging them for the way they dressed. And to be totally honest, I'm not a superhero guy. I never connected with the comics or the shows as a kid. But now I actually think real life superheroes, like El Peo Tignito, are way cooler than any Marvel or DC character.
加入他们的街区巡逻，并亲眼见证他们所做的工作。我被他们无私奉献帮助有需要的人的精神所激励。我也为自己曾因他们的穿着而对他们评头论足感到内疚。老实说，我不是个超级英雄迷。小时候我从没喜欢过漫画或相关节目。但现在我真的认为，像埃尔·皮亚托尼托这样的现实生活中的超级英雄，比任何漫威或DC的角色都要酷得多。
And there are a lot of civic doodgoaters who came before him. Take, for example, Jim Phillips, a Chicago middle school teacher from the 1960s, who called himself the Fox. The Fox says he took his name from the Fox River, which runs through Northern Illinois, west of Chicago. He's managed to avoid police and private detectives who tried to track him down.
在他之前有许多热心公益的善人。例如，20世纪60年代的一位芝加哥中学教师吉姆·菲利普斯，他自称为“狐狸”。“狐狸”说他的名字取自福克斯河，这条河穿过伊利诺伊州北部，在芝加哥以西。他设法躲避了试图追踪他的警察和私人侦探。
The Fox agreed to his first television interview. The Fox defended his community against the heartless corporations that were dumping toxic waste into local rivers. His calling card was a note signed with a fox face in place of the letter O. Legend has it, the fox would canoe down the river to put caps on drainage pipes that were releasing pollutants into the water. Once he even dumped 50 pounds of sewage from like Michigan into the office of the company responsible for it. In the early 1980s, another hero joined this tradition, a man named Willie Perry,
“狐狸”同意接受他的第一次电视采访。“狐狸”捍卫他的社区，对抗那些将有毒废物倾倒进当地河流的冷酷无情的公司。他的名片是一张用狐狸脸代替字母O的字条。传说中，“狐狸”会划着独木舟顺流而下，给那些向水中排放污染物的排水管加上盖子。有一次，他甚至将密歇根湖里50磅的污水倾倒进对此负有责任的公司的办公室里。在20世纪80年代初，另一位英雄加入了这一传统，一个名叫威利·佩里的男子，
who became known as the Birmingham Batman. Willie Perry drove around Birmingham, Alabama, in a souped up 1971 Ford Thunderbird with a Batman license plate in the words, Rescueship, painted on the hood. Mostly, he focused on helping stranded motorists. My car here was next to out. I didn't have a spare. And I was stranded. I was on the highway with my keys, move on, stop to help. And elongated, strange, calm. Today, there are actually dozens of good Samaritan heroes
他被称为“伯明翰蝙蝠侠”。威利·佩里驾驶着一辆改装过的1971年产福特雷鸟汽车在阿拉巴马州伯明翰四处行驶，车上挂着一个蝙蝠侠车牌，发动机罩上写着“救援船”几个字。他主要专注于帮助抛锚的司机。我这辆车当时快不行了。我没有备胎。我被困住了。我在高速公路上带着钥匙，然后有人停下来帮忙。而且，语气很奇怪，很冷静。如今，实际上有几十位善良的撒玛利亚人英雄
doing important civic work all around the world. For example, a woman in Nagoya, Japan, who goes by the moniker, Clean Panther. I guess there are about 40 heroes in Japan. Clean Panther wears a blue, red, and black kimono, with a futuristic yellow panther mask that covers her whole head. Many of the superheroes in Japan focus on picking up litter. My main activity is clean up town, so name it clean, and also combined with batter. I love black panther, the Marvel superhero. Clean Panther and her superhero crew would go on litter patrols, picking up trash in
在世界各地做着重要的公民工作。例如，日本名古屋的一位女士，她的代号是“洁净黑豹”。我想日本大概有40位英雄吧。洁净黑豹穿着一件蓝红相间的和服，戴着一个遮住整个头部的未来感黄色黑豹面具。日本的许多超级英雄都专注于捡垃圾。我的主要活动是清理城镇，所以叫“洁净”，同时也结合了蝙蝠侠。我喜欢漫威超级英雄黑豹。洁净黑豹和她的超级英雄团队会进行垃圾巡逻，在日本第四大城市名古屋捡拾垃圾。
Ngoia, Japan's fourth largest city. These heroes were important inspirations to modern do-gutters, like El Pé Neto, but the person who really inspired him, the most successful hero of them all, was Super Civico. In the mid-1990s, Super Civico roamed the streets of Bogota, Colombia. He wore yellow spandex, red underpants, and a cape with a letter C across his chest. His name literally translates to super-citizen. Super-Civico's real name is Antonis Mocos. He's a mathematician and philosopher with thick
这些英雄是现代热心公益者（如埃尔·皮亚托尼托）的重要灵感来源，但真正激励他、所有英雄中最成功的人是“超级市民”。在20世纪90年代中期，“超级市民”在哥伦比亚波哥大的街头游荡。他穿着黄色紧身衣、红色内裤，胸前印着一个字母C的斗篷。他的名字字面意思是“超级公民”。超级市民的真名是安塔纳斯·莫库斯。他是一位数学家和哲学家，戴着厚厚的眼镜，留着沙色的胡子。
glasses and a sandy beard. In 1993, Mocos was the chancellor of the National University of Columbia. At that time, the South American nation was in turmoil. The government was notoriously corrupt, kidnapping, assassinations, and extortion were common, as drug cartels and rebel groups like the FARC clashed with the government. The gap between the ultra-rich and everyone else seemed to be widening, as slums grew across the city.
1993年，莫库斯担任哥伦比亚国立大学校长。当时，这个南美国家正处于动荡之中。政府贪腐闻名，绑架、暗杀和敲诈勒索屡见不鲜，毒品卡特尔和反政府武装（如哥伦比亚革命武装力量）与政府发生冲突。随着贫民窟在城市中不断蔓延，超级富豪与其他人之间的差距似乎在拉大。
The local government of Bogota wasn't capable of meeting the basic needs of its citizens. And this unrest spilled out into every aspect of life, especially at the National University in Bogota. The students were fed up, many of them were sympathetic to the FARC, a Marxist rebel group. Others identified as anarchists, and together, they did seem to agree on one thing at least. They were not going to allow for peaceful discussions. This was war.
波哥大当地政府无力满足市民的基本需求。这种动荡蔓延到生活的方方面面，在波哥大的国立大学尤其严重。学生们受够了，他们中有许多人同情马克思主义反政府武装——哥伦比亚革命武装力量。其他人自认为是无政府主义者，而他们聚在一起，至少在一点上达成了共识。他们绝不允许和平讨论。这是一场战争。
At one campus event, students threw smoke bombs on the stage. Another time, they threw feces at the political candidates on stage for a debate. Mokus was attacked while giving his speech one day, but the next time he was confronted by the Raudy students, he did something that would shock the nation. On October 28th, 1993, Mokus walked to the edge of the stage, turned his back to the crowd, pulled down his pants, and moond them. The Mokus moonding set a pretty clear message to the protesters and it became national news. Now typically showing your butthole to thousands of students would be a career ending move. And in one way it was, he didn't work at the university after that. But it also made him a star. Many Colombians found the whole thing refreshing.
在校园的一次活动中，学生们向舞台上扔了烟雾弹。另一次，他们向参加辩论的候选人扔粪便。有一天，莫库斯在演讲时遭到袭击，但下一次当他面对吵闹的学生时，他做了一件震惊全国的事。1993年10月28日，莫库斯走到舞台边缘，背对着人群，脱下裤子，露出了屁股。莫库斯露屁股的举动向抗议者发出了非常明确的信息，并成为了全国新闻。通常情况下，向数千名学生露出肛门会是一场断送职业生涯的举动。从某种意义上说确实如此，他后来没有在大学工作了。但这也让他成了一个明星。许多哥伦比亚人觉得整件事令人耳目一新。
This is a clip from a short film called Cities on Speed, Bogota Change. The mooning incident becomes a national scandal, and Mogos is forced to resign his position. But among the general public, he becomes a symbol of honesty. Moku's sudden popularity inspires him to run for mayor. Against all tradition, he runs as an independent without support from any political party. Antonis Moku won the election in a landslide and became the first independent candidate to become mayor of Bogota. And once he took office, he made it clear that he was unlike any politician Bogota had ever seen.
这是名为《速度之城：波哥大变革》的短片剪辑。露屁股事件演变成了一场全国丑闻，莫库斯被迫辞职。但在广大公众中，他成为了诚实的象征。莫库斯突如其来的受欢迎程度激发了他竞选市长的灵感。打破所有传统，他以独立身份参选，没有得到任何政党的支持。安塔纳斯·莫库斯在选举中大胜，成为第一位当选波哥大市长的独立候选人。一旦上任，他就表明自己不同于波哥大见过的任何政客。
He would bring props to interviews, like a giant stuffed carrot, which is the word used in Columbia to call someone a nerd. At one point, he got 45,000 citizens to gather in the streets and inflate balloons. They were painted with the image of someone who had persecuted them in some way. The citizens popped the balloons in a form of city-wide performance therapy. Mokus' methods were unusual. But nothing prepared people for Mokus' greatest stunt of all. He began patrolling the streets as Super Sivico. As far as I can tell, Mocus was the first political leader to create a superhero identity
他会把道具带到采访中，比如一个巨大的毛绒胡萝卜（在哥伦比亚这是用来称呼书呆子的词）。有一次，他召集了45,000名市民走上街头，吹起气球。气球上画着曾经在某种程度上迫害过他们的人的形象。市民们通过扎破气球来进行一种全市范围的行为艺术治疗。莫库斯的方法不同寻常。但没有什么能比莫库斯最伟大的壮举更让人猝不及防了。他开始以“超级市民”的身份在街头巡逻。据我所知，莫库斯是第一位创造超级英雄身份
complete with a costume and then walk the streets as a superhero. Here is a news clip of Super Sivico in action. A news reporter walks alongside Mocus, who's wearing skin-tight yellow spandex. As they walk, SuperCivico tears down old crumbling posters from a wall and collects trash that he takes to a dumpster. He says to the reporter, we want to have a beautiful city. The reporter narrates the video as SuperCivico jumps onto a concrete wall and starts running. His red cape flowing behind him.
并配备服装、然后以超级英雄身份走上街头的政治领袖。这是一段“超级市民”在行动的新闻剪辑。一名新闻记者与穿着紧身黄色紧身衣的莫库斯并肩行走。在他们走动时，“超级市民”从墙上撕下残破的老旧海报，收集垃圾扔进垃圾桶。他对记者说，我们想要一个美丽的城市。当“超级市民”跳上一堵水泥墙并开始奔跑时，记者为视频进行旁白。他红色的斗篷在身后随风飘扬。
As the reporter says, using his super legs, he climbs the protest against visual pollution. One time, SuperCivico turned up on TV naked and took a shower while promoting increased water conservation. And it worked. After his stunt, water use in the city dropped by roughly 14%. As mayor of Bogota, Mokus embraced the idea of street theater, sometimes in ways that baffled even his supporters. For example, he fired all of the notoriously corrupt traffic police. And he told them if they wanted to be rehired, they would first have to be trained as professional mimes. Yes, you heard that right, mimes. Most of the traffic police scoffed, but about 400 did return to the force. And so, across Bogota, the people saw something extraordinary.
正如记者所说，他利用他的超级双腿，攀爬抗议视觉污染。有一次，“超级市民”赤裸着身子出现在电视上，在宣传节约用水的同时洗了个澡。这起到了作用。在他的特技表演后，该市的用水量下降了大约14%。作为波哥大市长，莫库斯接受了街头剧场的概念，有时其方式甚至让他的支持者感到困惑。例如，他解雇了所有臭名昭著的腐败交通警察。他告诉他们，如果想被重新录用，必须首先接受专业哑剧演员的培训。是的，你没听错，哑剧演员。大多数交警对此嗤之以鼻，但大约有400人回到了警队。因此，在整个波哥大，人们看到了非同寻常的一幕。
Over 400 mimes with white painted faces and fluorescent dungarees fanned out across the city. They would hand out soccer-style red cards and mock drivers who flaunted the rules. It sounds absurd, but this actually makes sense to me. I think it's far too easy for us to be reactionary, to respond with anger when we're told that we are wrong. But by using humor and street theater, it changes the whole equation. It's a lot harder to get mad at a mime or a guy in a cape because you look ridiculous.
400多名涂着白脸、穿着荧光背带裤的哑剧演员散布在城市的各个角落。他们会拿出足球风格的红牌，嘲笑那些无视规则的司机。这听起来很荒谬，但这对我来说确实合乎情理。我认为我们太容易产生对抗情绪，当被告知我们错了时，往往会用愤怒来回应。但通过运用幽默和街头剧场，它改变了整个等式。对一个哑剧演员或一个披着斗篷的人发火要困难得多，因为你自己看起来就很荒谬。
The mime patrol brings down the temperature. And ultimately, the best argument for Mokas' methods were the results he achieved. There was a 50% drop in traffic fatalities under Mokas. This superhero mayor, Super Civico, also brought down homicide rates by 70%. Mokas served one term as mayor, which is the maximum there because of term limits. After leaving office Moga's ran for president of Columbia in 1998, he lost, but in 2001, he came back to Bogota and won a second term as mayor before stepping down in 2003.
哑剧巡逻队缓和了气氛。归根结底，支持莫库斯方法的最好论据是他所取得的成果。在莫库斯任职期间，交通死亡人数下降了50%。这位超级英雄市长“超级市民”还将凶杀率降低了70%。莫库斯担任了一届市长，由于任期限制，这是那里的最高年限。卸任后，莫库斯于1998年竞选哥伦比亚总统，但失败了；但在2001年，他回到波哥大并赢得了第二任市长，直到2003年卸任。
SuperCivico is no longer doing good deeds on the streets of Bogota, but his street theater revolution has inspired another generation of heroes, including a young political science student named Jorge. A.K.A. the Crosse walk crusader. A.K.A. he who can stop a Jeep with his bare hands on the streets of Los Angeles. Jorge grew up in Mexico City, whereas a, he was afraid to walk the streets. They were chaotic cars everywhere. It was very dangerous, noise, pollution. So yeah, it was hostile and stressful to walk. So I always told my mother that I don't like to walk the streets. It's terrible. He became passionate about road safety, but he had a hard time getting others to share his excitement.
“超级市民”不再在波哥大的街头做好事，但他的街头剧场革命启发了新一代的英雄，其中包括一位名叫豪尔赫的年轻政治学学生。又名十字路口卫士。又名那个能在洛杉矶街头赤手空拳拦下一辆吉普车的人。豪尔赫在墨西哥城长大，在那里，他害怕走在街上。到处都是混乱的汽车。非常危险，充满噪音和污染。所以，是的，走路充满了敌意和压力。所以我总是告诉母亲我不喜欢走在街上。太可怕了。他对道路安全充满了热情，但他很难让别人分享他的兴奋。
One night in February of 2012, Jorge and his best friend went to catch a lucha libre wrestling match. And it was something they did all the time, but that night was different. Jorge watched the masked luchador fighters throw each other around the ring in their gleaming costumes, and a crazy idea popped into his head. The theatrics of the luchilebre made him think of Antonis Mokas. What if he followed
2012年2月的一个晚上，豪尔赫和他的最好朋友去看了一场自由摔角比赛。这是他们经常做的事情，但那天晚上与众不同。豪尔赫看着戴着面具的摔角手们在闪亮的服装中把彼此扔进擂台，一个疯狂的想法闯入了他的脑海。自由摔角的戏剧性让他想起了安塔纳斯·莫库斯。如果他追随
in Mokas' footsteps and used the iconic Mexican luchidor as a vehicle to spread the word about better urban planning? You know people love to see a theater and spectacles in the streets, and that's a great way to send a message in a peaceful way. We need to do something fun. Why not after the match we buy a cape and a mask and go out to the streets to fight for the rights of pedestrians? And just like that, a new hero was born. El Péato Nito, that's Spanish for the pedestrian. For his first few outings, El Péato Nito wore a $3 cape.
莫库斯的脚步，将标志性的墨西哥摔角手作为传播有关更好城市规划信息的工具会怎样？你知道人们喜欢看街头的戏剧和奇观，这是以和平方式传达信息的绝佳途径。我们需要做一些有趣的事情。为什么不在比赛结束后买一件斗篷和面具，走上街头为行人的权利而战呢？就这样，一个新英雄诞生了。埃尔·皮亚托尼托，在西班牙语中是“行人”的意思。在最初的几次出行中，埃尔·皮亚托尼托穿着一件3美元的斗篷。
Then he got an upgrade. I told my grandmother to help me design my cape. And my cape has white and black stripes, just like pedestrian crosswalk. With his new suit, L. Paye Tignito set out to brave the onslaught of rush hour in Mexico City. He wove through road raging drivers and toxic exhaust fumes with his black and white crosswalk cape streaming out behind him. I push back cars that are obstructing the crosswalk. I paint the sidewalks and I paint crosswalks and bikeways without any permits. Did anyone try to fight you when you would go out? A few times, yes.
后来他升级了装备。我告诉祖母帮我设计斗篷。我的斗篷有白色的黑条纹，就像行人过路斑马线一样。穿着新制服，埃尔·皮亚托尼托出发去迎接墨西哥城交通高峰期的冲击。他穿梭于路怒司机和有毒的尾气之中，身后飘扬着黑白斑马线斗篷。我推开挡在人行横道上的汽车。我在没有人任何许可的情况下粉刷人行道，粉刷斑马线和自行车道。你出去的时候有人试图跟你打架吗？有过几次，是的。
Especially when I walk on the top of cars. This is El Pea Tornito's most controversial tactic. He walks on the top of cars to really make the driver feel shame for their bad behavior. The owners get mad and they start to be aggressive, but then I'm very friendly. You know, I do my best to never escalate conflict. Pea Tnito doesn't think of his luchador persona as a character he's playing. It's just him, a mild mannered academic in a costume that has meant to draw attention
特别是当我走在汽车顶部时。这是埃尔·皮亚托尼托最具争议的战术。他走在汽车顶部，好让司机真正为他们的不良行为感到羞耻。车主们很生气，开始变得具有攻击性，但接着我表现得很友好。你知道，我尽最大努力绝不升级冲突。皮亚托尼托不认为他的摔角手角色是他正在扮演的角色。这只是他自己，一个温和的学者，穿着一件旨在以引人入胜的方式吸引人们对一个非常严重的问题的注意力的服装
to a very serious problem in an engaging way. It's a challenge because we have normalized chaotic streets. We have normalized that if somebody dies in the streets, it was an accident. Advocates, we hate the word accident because there are not accidents. Somebody designed the street. Somebody was a reckless driver.
这是一个挑战，因为我们已经将混乱的街道标准化了。我们已经将如果有人死于街头视为一场意外这一现象标准化了。倡导者们，我们讨厌“意外”这个词，因为根本没有意外。有人设计了这条街道。有人是个鲁莽的司机。
After graduating from high school, Jorge moved to Los Angeles to study urban planning at UCLA. After that, he stayed in LA to work on infrastructure issues. He made a capstone project called the pedestrian battle of Los Angeles, named for the Regigants the Machine Alpum. His work is based on a global campaign called Vision Zero, which is pushing for communities around the world to reach the goal of zero traffic fatalities and severe injuries. But his work isn't just academic. Every so often, he still pulls out the cape and mask. On a recent Saturday afternoon last summer, El Peato Nito was fully clad in his luchidor
高中毕业后，豪尔赫搬到洛杉矶，在UCLA（加州大学洛杉矶分校）学习城市规划。之后，他留在洛杉矶从事基础设施问题的工作。他做一个名为“洛杉矶行人战役”的毕业设计作品，名字取自“机器怒汉”乐队的专辑。他的工作基于一项名为“零愿景”的全球运动，该运动推动世界各地的社区实现零交通死亡和严重受伤的目标。但他的工作不仅仅是学术性的。每隔一段时间，他仍然会拿出斗篷和面具。去年夏天的最近一个星期六下午，埃尔·皮亚托尼托全套武装地穿着他的摔角手
mask and cape prowling the streets of Los Angeles, on the lookout for anyone who might be putting pedestrians in danger. And it didn't take long for him to encounter his first villain. A guy parked his car in a crosswalk and then walked inside a restaurant where he stood in line waiting to pick up food. So Paya Taniuto went up to the window of the restaurant and tried to get the guys attention.
面具和斗篷在洛杉矶街头徘徊，寻找任何可能将行人置于危险境地的人。没过多久，他就遇到了他的第一个恶棍。一个家伙把车停在人行横道上，然后走进一家餐馆，在队伍中排队等候买食物。于是皮亚托尼托走到餐馆窗户前，试图引起那个家伙的注意。
But the crosswalk menace was unfazed by the man in the luch door mask and Kate calling him out. He pretended like he didn't see Péritanito. He's ignoring me, you know? Like, you're parked in the crosswalk. You know, I'm not going to be viled in, you know? Like, that's not my style. But at least he knows that he's doing something illegal
但这个横穿马路的威胁对戴着摔角手面具和斗篷呼喊他的男人无动于衷。他假装没看到皮亚托尼托。他在忽视我，你知道吗？就像，你把车停在人行横道上。你知道，我不会动粗的，你知道吗？就像，那不是我的风格。但至少他知道自己在做违法的事
and he shouldn't be parked on the crosswalk. Paya Teneito's goal is to get people's attention. He wants everyone to look at the folks who are putting pedestrians in danger. He wants them to feel shame and to change their naughty ways. The absurdity of facing down a superhero forces drivers to think differently about car culture. In a city where five or six pedestrians die every week from car-related incidents. You know, don't take me wrong. The car is a great invention, and yeah, there's something of freedom about cars. But if we analyze the numbers of crashes, pollution, space taken by cars, we have failed this experiment.
而且他不应该把车停在人行横道上。皮亚托尼托的目标是吸引人们的注意。他希望每个人都看到那些将行人置于危险境地的家伙。他希望他们感到羞耻并改变他们的顽固行径。与超级英雄面对面的荒谬感迫使司机对汽车文化有不同的思考。在一个每周有五到六名行人死于汽车相关事故的城市里。你知道，不要误会我的意思。汽车是一项伟大的发明，是的，汽车有一种自由感。但如果我们分析车祸、污染以及汽车占据的空间等数据，我们在这个实验上已经失败了。
For all his theatrics, El Péri-Tanito's work on the streets can only accomplish so much. For bigger changes to happen, we need activism on a broader scale. That's why Péri-Tanito works alongside other pedestrian activists, and a grassroots organization called Sunset for All. They put together a proposal to improve the city's bike lane infrastructure and to improve sidewalks, build more shade structures, and bus stops, and expand access to public parks. In September, Los Angeles City Council member Mitch O'Farell issued a formal motion to support their project. It was a small but important victory for the people fighting in the pedestrian battle
尽管有种种戏剧性表演，埃尔·皮亚托尼托在街头的工作也只能取得这么多成效。要发生更大的改变，我们需要更大规模的行动主义。这就是为什么皮亚托尼托与其他行人活动人士以及一个名为“全员日落大道”的基层组织并肩作战。他们提出了一项提案，旨在改善城市的自行车道基础设施、改善人行道、建造更多的遮阳设施和公交车站，并扩大公共公园的准入。9月份，洛杉矶市议员米奇·奥法雷尔发布了一项正式动议，以支持他们的项目。对于在洛杉矶行人战役中战斗的人们来说，这是一场虽小但意义重大的胜利。
of Los Angeles. I love El Peo Tnito and the fun and absurdity that he brings to everyday life. But for real change to happen, we also need different kinds of heroes, bold thinking community members who become leaders for the right reason, to serve the people, leaders who will actually bring meaningful change to our neighborhoods. More with David Weinberg after this. So I'm back with David Weinberg. Hey David.
我喜欢埃尔·皮亚托尼托以及他带给日常生活中的趣味和荒谬感。但要实现真正的改变，我们还需要不同种类的英雄，那些出于正确原因挺身而出、服务于人民的大胆思考的社区成员领袖，那些真正能为我们的社区带来意义深远改变的领袖。接下来还有大卫·温伯格的更多内容。所以我回来了，和David Weinberg在一起。嘿，大卫。
Hey Robin, how's it going? I'm really good. Thank you for that story. It was so much fun. You recently made a whole show about real life superheroes called superhero complex. And for, you know, for our show, we talked about some of the more civic-minded, friendly real life superheroes. But on your show, you do some research and talk about a kind of more sinister, vigilante flipside. Yeah, it's true, but these are not people that I've spent time with. I was looking back through history at people who've maybe set a precedent for the real life superhero movement, folks who've taken the law into their own hands.
嘿，罗宾，最近怎么样？我真的很好。谢谢你带来的故事。太有趣了。你最近做了一整档关于现实生活超级英雄的节目，叫《超级英雄综合症》。而且你知道的，为了我们的节目，我们讨论了一些更具公民意识、更友善的现实生活中的超级英雄。但在你的节目中，你做了一些研究，并谈到了更具阴暗面、义务治安员的反面。是的，确实如此，但这些并不是我花时间相处的人。我在回顾历史，寻找那些可能为现实生活中的超级英雄运动开创先例的人，那些将法律抓在自己手里的人。
And in the US, vigilantes have looked like a lot of things, sometimes really ugly, like the clan or insurrectionists. And one group that I read up on who actually have similarities to real life superheroes is a group called the Bald Nobbers. The Bald Nobbers were an example of this sort of group that wore masks and they executed vigilante justice in the wild west. So this is T. Crulos. He's the author of a book called Heroes in the Night
在美国，义务治安员看起来有很多种面孔，有时真的很丑陋，比如三K党或暴徒。我读过的一个群体，其实与现实生活中的超级英雄有相似之处，他们是一个叫做“秃头山民”的组织。“秃头山民”就是这种在荒野西部戴着面具执行私刑正义的群体的一个例子。这位是T·克鲁洛斯。他是《暗夜英雄》一书的作者
Inside the Real Life Superhero Movement. And he writes about the bald nobbers. They were active in Missouri from 1885 to 1889. And they looked pretty terrifying. They wore like suit coats, backwards, and they dawned at these homemade masks that had devil horns protruding from the top. And this red and white stitching around their eyes and mouth.
走进现实生活中的超级英雄运动。他写到了“秃头山民”。他们在1855年至1889年间在密苏里州活跃。他们看起来相当可怕。他们把西装外套反着穿，并戴上这些自制的面具，面具顶部伸出恶魔之角。眼睛和嘴巴周围有红白相间的缝线。
I imagine it would have been like terrifying to see these guys like galloping across the plains on horseback and whips in their hands and they're basically looking to kill suspected horse thieves. So they started out by hanging people that were cattle thieves or stuff like that. But as their reign sort of went on, they became a little bit more petty, I think, like you could be visited by the bald nobbers and whipped if you were accused of being ornery. Yeah, and it wasn't just people with an
我想象着，看到这些家伙骑着马在平原上驰骋，手里挥舞着鞭子，基本上是为了寻找并杀死可疑的偷马贼，那一定会非常可怕。所以他们一开始是绞死那些偷牛贼或类似的人。但随着他们的统治继续，他们变得有点琐碎了，我想，比如如果你被指控脾气暴躁，你可能会遭到秃头山民的拜访和鞭打。是的，山民们追捕的目标不仅限于那些
irritable disposition that the nobbers went after. Back then, a lot of the poor couples in the community, they couldn't afford to pay their marriage license fees, so they were technically not married, but they lived together as a family. And the bald nobbers believed these unwed couples were living in sin, and so they basically went around just beating these people. It's kind of an example of vigilanteism that's fun out of control. As time goes on, you get other groups that I would say are similar to that. You have groups like the Minutemen who patrol the border. They're also armed. You have groups like the Guardian Angels who are not armed, but are also, you know, in a sort of uniform slash costume that patrol the streets, looking for crimes. Do you find that a group like this, like the bald numbers, has some DNA with real life
脾气暴躁的人。那时，社区里的许多贫穷夫妇负担不起结婚证费用，所以从技术上讲他们没有结婚，但他们作为一家人生活在一起。秃头山民认为这些未婚夫妇生活在罪恶中，所以他们基本上到处殴打这些人。这是私刑失控的一个例子。随着时间的推移，你还会遇到其他我可以说与之类似的组织。你有像巡逻边境的“民兵”这样的组织。他们也是武装的。你有像“守护天使”这样的组织，他们虽然没有武装，但也穿着某种制服/服装巡逻街道，寻找犯罪。你觉得像这样的一群人，比如秃头山民，与现实生活中的
superhero movement or is this a totally different thing? You know, I think one thing that all the real life superheroes had in common with the bald numbers is that they all believed in their hearts that they were out to do good. And the difference, I think, is that a lot of the real life superiors are actually doing good and their intentions are good. But with the bald nobbers, I would say a lot of their intentions were not good and things got out of hand quickly.
超级英雄运动有一些共同的基因吗？还是这完全是两码事？你知道，我认为所有现实生活中的超级英雄与秃头山民的共同点在于，他们内心都坚信自己是在行善。而区别在于，我认为许多现实生活的超级英雄实际上在行善，他们的动机是好的。但对于秃头山民，我要说他们的许多动机并不好，事情很快就失控了。
And another key distinction is that the bald nobbers had weapons. They were shootouts and whips. And every single real life superhero that I talked to was vehemilia posed to any sort of weapon or gun that was sort of like against their ethos. How does the existence of this darker element impact
另一个关键区别在于，秃头山民拥有武器。他们有枪战和鞭子。而我采访过的每一个现实生活中的超级英雄都坚决反对任何形式的武器或枪支，这某种程度上违背了他们的精神信仰。这种更黑暗元素的存在如何影响
how you think about real life superheroes? Like the impulse towards, you know, vigilanceism could be civic minded, but also it could be, you know, really bad. So having seen all sides of this, what do you think of this desire people have to take the law into their own hands? Well, I think the desire to do good in your community
你对现实生活中的超级英雄的看法？比如对私刑的冲动可能具有公民意识，但也可能真的很糟糕。所以看过这一切的各个方面后，你如何看待人们这种将法律掌握在自己手中的渴望？嗯，我认为在你的社区里行善的渴望
is a good one. And I will say that all the real life superheroes that I spent time with for the show had good intentions. And I would say I largely agree with their intentions and the things they were trying to do, where it gets complicated is a lot of times, you know, in my reporting, I found situations where the real life superheroes stepped into a situation
是一个好渴望。我要说的是，为了这档节目，我与之共度时光的所有现实生活中的超级英雄都有着良好的意图。而且我要说，我很大程度上赞同他们的意图以及他们试图做的事情，复杂的地方在于很多时候，你知道，在我的报道中，我发现了一些现实生活中的超级英雄介入某种情况的情况，
and I think sometimes it got worse. And part of that, I think, is that if you're gonna be the type of person that's gonna take the lawn to your own hands or just go into these situations that can get very dangerous very quickly, there has to be some level of training and we all have to agree as a society, like how we want people to handle a lot.
而我认为有时情况变得更糟了。部分原因我认为是，如果你要成为那种把法律抓在自己手里的人，或者只是卷入这些可能很快变得非常危险的情况中，就必须有一定程度的培训，而且作为社会，我们都必须就我们希望人们如何处理法律达成一致。
Ideally, it would be to de-escalate these situations. And when you have real life superheroes, we don't have that oversight over them. They're just operating on their own. And so that's where I think it gets kind of messy, even when their intentions are good. Yeah, well, this is really fascinating as a culture and I hope people check out the superhero complex
理想情况下，会是缓和这些情况。而当你拥有现实生活中的超级英雄时，我们对他们没有这种监督。他们只是在独自行动。所以这就是我认为事情变得有些混乱的地方，即使他们的动机是好的。是的，作为一种文化，这真的很迷人，我希望人们去看看《超级英雄综合症》，
because it's such a good series. I really appreciate you making it. Oh, thank you so much. This is really lovely to hear. Thanks for sharing part of the story with us, David. Yeah, anytime. 99% Invisible with Produce this week by David Weinberg, edited by Chris Barupé, original music by Swan Riel, sound mix by Martin Gonzales, fact checking by Graham Haysha. Our senior editor is Delaney Hall, Kurt Colstead is the digital director, Residine includes
因为它是一部非常棒的系列剧。非常感谢你制作了它。哦，非常感谢。听到这话真好。谢谢你和我们分享部分故事，大卫。随时奉陪。“99%隐形”本周由大卫·温伯格制作，克里斯·巴鲁佩剪辑，原创音乐由斯旺·里尔创作，声音混音由马丁·冈萨雷斯负责，事实核查由格雷厄姆·海沙完成。我们的资深编辑是德兰妮·霍尔，库尔特·科尔斯特德是数字总监，制作人员包括
Jason D'Alyone, Emmett Fitzgerald, Christopher Johnson, Vivian Leigh, Lashmadan, Jacob Maldonado Medina, Kelly Prime, Joe Rosenberg, Sophia Klatsker, intern Olivia Green, and me Roman Mars. Special thanks to David Waters, Carolyn Thornham, and Amalia Sortland. We are part of the Stitcher & Serious XM Podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building, in beautifultown Oakland California. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI org.PI.org. Tell me what you do me a favor.
杰森·达利奥内、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、维维安·李、拉什马丹、雅各布·马尔多纳多·梅迪纳、凯利·普赖姆、乔·罗森伯格、索菲亚·克拉茨克，实习生奥利维亚·格林，以及我罗曼·马尔斯。特别感谢大卫·沃特斯、卡罗琳·索恩姆和阿马利亚·索特兰。我们是Stitcher & Sirius XM播客家族的一部分，总部现在位于美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心以北六个街区的潘多拉大楼。你可以在Facebook上找到这个节目并参与讨论。你可以在Twitter上@我（Roman Mars）以及节目（@99PI.org）。答应我一件事。
I want you to tell all your friends about me. What are you? I'm Stitcher. Get out! I'm Stitcher. Yeah! My favorite one is I swear to God. Swear to me! There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我要你把所有朋友都介绍给我。你是谁？我是Stitcher。滚开！我是Stitcher。耶！我最喜欢的一个是我发誓。向我发誓！本期节目目前还没有评论。点击转录文本中的任何句子即可发表评论。